[Music]
we are just three days away from a
possible second government shutdown
maybe of the new year chief
congressional correspondent Michael Mann
was on Capitol Hill with a status report
tonight tonight House Republicans will
meet to discuss funding the government
facing a Thursday night deadline sources
tell Fox a six-week extension through
March 22nd or so is likely since
Democrats have not agreed to a spending
caps deal and one option is adding more
national security money to win over
defense Hawks there's no reason why our
warfighters they need to continue to
face uncertainty until all the other
issues are resolved that idea is not
placating the Democrats Senate leader
there isn't much time to waste
and yet speaker Ryan is again
considering a cromnibus
a short-term extension of funding for
urgent domestic priorities but a
long-term extension and a large increase
of funding for defense
speaker Ryan said lawmakers were making
progress on setting spending levels but
needed more time after a brief
government shutdown in January over daca
those young people brought to this
country illegally by their parents
Democrats don't sound eager to repeat
that drama I don't see a government
shutdown coming but I do see a promise
by Senator McConnell to finally bring
this critical issue that affects the
lives of hundreds of thousands of people
in America finally bringing it to a full
debate in the Senate today senators John
McCain and Chris Coons offered a
bipartisan immigration plan the White
House was quick to reject it because it
does not provide money for the
president's border wall proposal and
does not end chain migration or the
diversity visa program these two
programs risk exploitation from those
who do not share our values and actively
work to undermine them Coons called the
proposal a good starting point for a
Senate debate it lays out a plan a
pathway towards securing control of the
border by 2020
Republicans note President Trump made a
serious offer including a path to
citizenship for 1.8 million people and
Democrats must decide if they want a
solution or
campaign issue I certainly hope there
should be a deal get this off the table
take care of these young people that are
here and again if the Democrat has
turned it down there should be an issue
against some of the campaign Fox is told
part of the pitch tonight to House
Republicans will be including more money
for the military and extending popular
health care spending such as community
health centers looking for the right
combination of yes votes Bret McMahon
you live on the hill Mike thanks